Привет! В прошлом уроке мы собрали компонентную базу на реакте и быстро глянули на тестовой страничке, что всё это принеслось, всё это работает. Бегло по верхам пробежались, сегодня мы заводим полноценный каталог компонентов, который называется Storybook. Это витрина, где каждый компонент стоит отдельно со всеми вариантами, состояниями и блоками-песочницами, в которых можно посмотреть, как всё это работает. Зачем он нам? Тут две задачи.
Первая — это нормально сверить зеркало по каждому компоненту во всех состояниях, а не по одной общей страничке. И вторая — каталог — это та форма, в которой работу принято отдавать разработке.
Сейчас у нас одна страничка, на которой сразу всё. Когда компонентная база такая небольшая, как сейчас у меня, это нормально, да, можно с этим всем работать.
Но, конечно, если у тебя там больше сотни компонентов, то должен быть более структурный формат взаимодействия с этим. Это сегодня мы и построим.
Итак, чтобы было понятно, зачем вообще тратим на это отдельный урок, что нам даёт этот каталог?
Первое — это компонент в изоляции. Смотришь не весь экран, а одну отдельную кнопку, один input отдельно без шума вокруг и с возможностью посмотреть, как он ведёт себя в тех или иных ситуациях.
Второе — это все варианты и состояние разума, primary, secondary, ghost, плюс один отдельный компонент, который все их учитывает.
Это важно, чтобы разработчик мог сразу открыть, посмотреть, как это действительно должно работать, посмотреть разум все состояния и как этот компонент, ну, вообще, в принципе, должен работать и взаимодействовать с какими-то другими схожими компонентами из той же среды.
Это даёт общее представление о том, что нужно реализовать и как оно должно работать.
Ну и третье — это песочницы. По каждой группе компонентов собираются отдельные блоки, в которых можно всё покрутить, посмотреть, ну, сегодня мы ещё увидим, как это выглядит.
Также в Storybook собираются песочницы, в которых можно посмотреть, как это всё должно выглядеть, как это работает, как одни компоненты с другими взаимодействуют, как меняется их состояние, как предусматриваются какие-то edge-кейсы и так далее.
На таком общем блоке, в котором собрано всё. Ещё посмотрим, как это будет выглядеть.
И четвёртое — это форма передачи. Разработчик получает живой каталог, вот компоненты, вот их состояние, вот как они себя ведут, берёт готовое и переиспользует.
Сегодня мы ещё посмотрим, как правильно передать разработчику эти наработки.
Поэтому важно, чтобы этот каталог получился аккуратный, качественный.
И дальше мы посмотрим, как его собрать, как это всё выглядит и сделаем это, как обычно, с помощью директивы.
Для этого у нас есть уже новая директива Storybook, точно так же перекидываем агенту и просим её выполнить.
По большому счёту мы можем просто сказать агенту: «Собери мне Storybook», и он с этими компонентами их соберёт.
Но здесь в директиве я предусмотрел, чтобы он ещё собирал вот эти самые песочницы, потому что делает он это не всегда.
Чтобы он нормально всё это дело структурировал, накидывал сразу базово анимации и отслеживал разные поведения и состояния.
Ну и в целом заложено, что он должен создавать именно те же самые компоненты с привязкой ко всем переменным, неймингу и так далее.
Базово он всё это дело собрал, даже запустил локалку, мы уже знаем, что это такое.
И здесь он предлагает добавить какие-то дополнительные состояния, микроанимации и так далее.
Я нажму «Да», чтобы всё у нас было красиво.
Это просто предусмотренная директива.
И, кстати, можем уже сейчас перейти по этой ссылке, открыть Storybook и посмотреть, как это тут всё работает.
Давайте, чтобы было удобнее смотреть, открою в браузере, чтобы у нас просто места побольше было.
Итак, здесь мы видим, что он создал все наши компоненты отдельными слотами, с каждым из них можно ознакомиться.
Для Foundation у нас вообще отдельная подгруппа, это не компоненты.
Есть у нас бэджи, вот так они выглядят у меня, работает, прогноз и так далее.
Здесь описаны сразу все состояния, можно на них посмотреть, как они выглядят, скопировать код, посмотреть код, как он может выглядеть в проекте.
Мы не разработчики, конечно, за нас всё это будет делать агент.
Но если ты передаёшь это разрабу, я уверен, он скажет спасибо и это будет намного удобнее.
Но я уверен, если ты в таком виде все апдейты будешь передавать разрабу, это, конечно, сильно скажется на скорости его работы.
Ну, также здесь отдельно можно посмотреть на Success, Warning, Error, как они выглядят.
Также здесь к этим компонентам уже добавляются их варианты, те, которые у нас в Figma созданы, здесь всё то же самое.
Текст, который внутри находится, это ещё одно свойство, которое будет меняться.
Ну и название класса, здесь это нам не нужно.
То же самое для хлебных крошек.
Описание, как он называется, какие у него есть там вариации, как он может выглядеть в коде.
Плюс предусмотрены там анимации при наведении и так далее.
Как это выглядит дефолтно и при коротком пути.
Вот, например, на таблице в доках особенно видно, как это вообще работает.
То есть у нас есть таблица и у таблицы может быть много нюансов.
Может быть таблица поменьше, побольше, может быть там пять колонок, шесть, семь и так далее.
Может текст переполняться или не переполняться.
Может места для таблицы хватать или не хватать.
Всё это нужно предусмотреть, как оно должно выглядеть.
Если ты просто кидаешь там в фигме компоненты, показываешь, что вот такое мне собери.
Ну, тут будет появляться много нюансов, которые нужно будет дорабатывать.
Здесь же описание всех возможных там вариаций, как это структурно в коде выглядит.
С привязкой тому, как у нас этот компонент собран в фигме.
И здесь вот, например, он показывает разные вариации.
Например, дефолтный, когда обычная таблица, пять колонок большого размера.
Более компактная её вариация для каких-то там отдельных кейсов.
Когда у нас очень много контента, как будет выглядеть overflow, переполнение,
как это всё дело должно скроллиться.
Ну, вот тут, например, я уже вижу, что эту историю я хочу, чтобы она фиксировалась сверху.
Поэтому уже сейчас я агенту могу это сказать, что здесь неправильно это реализовано.
Надо, чтобы вот эта первая строка самая крепилась к самому верху.
Дальше как это выглядит, если у нас в ячейке слишком длинный текст.
Ну и отдельно все эти вариации.
С foundation тут всё попроще.
Цвета перенесены, спейсинги, радиусы перенесены.
Так же, как это выглядит у нас в Figma.
Ну и с типографикой всё то же самое.
Ну и отдельно отметим песочницы сэндбоксов, о которых я ранее говорил.
Здесь сейчас он уже мне всё докрутил, всё доделал.
Я также дополнительно попросил его закинуть сюда иконки из той библиотеки, которую я ранее использовал.
И теперь, что вообще это за сэндбокс, как это выглядит.
Здесь такие гипотетически собираются компоненты, которые позволяют посмотреть, как это всё будет работать.
То есть, в сэндбоксах далеко не факт, что всё, что тут собирается, действительно будет использоваться у тебя там в проекте.
Это просто такой тестовый стенд, на котором можно посмотреть поведение.
Вот, например, у нас модальное окно, как оно будет выглядеть, какая тут у нас компоновка, размеры, что-нибудь пишем, нажимаем удалить, открыть модалку снова.
Здесь можно, например, отработать то, как она будет появляться.
Сейчас, например, она резко исчезает, мне это не нравится, я могу сказать агенту об этом.
Форма, опять же, нажали создать, посмотрели, как выглядит состояние ошибки, введите имя сервера, что-нибудь вписываем, нажимаем создать, уже ошибки нет.
Показать список операционных систем, здесь, например, у нас странно выглядит вот этот, здесь у нас странно выглядит дропдаун, то есть он открывается почему-то вот через отдельную кнопку.
Это также можно доработать, ему сказать уже на этом этапе, что этот паттерн, ну блин, точно неправильный.
Навигация, смотрим, как выглядит навбар, как он по ширине распределяется, можно оценить здесь вот эту адаптивность.
Точно также хлебные крошки, как выглядят, как у нас переключаются табы, как у нас работают страницы, когда их больше, например, четырех.
У нас разделяется они такой пагинацией, смотрим, как это работает, как у нас сменяются цифры, состояние активности, что происходит, когда мы доходим до последних страниц, остается только один вот этот блок пагинации.
Отрабатывать это компонентом было бы долго, неудобно, здесь мы можем сразу на стенде при создании компонентов посмотреть, как это работает.
Данные, обратная связь, здесь также он там показывает, как выглядят всплывающие уведомления, как выглядят всплывающие уведомления, здесь какие-то тул типы.
Дальше, дашборд серверов, опять же, при наведении у нас тут возникают эти тул типы, компонент уже отдельный был, как отображаются конфигурации, там регионы, статусы, состояние при наведении.
Дальше, создание сервера, также мы тут выбираем, здесь, например, мне не нравится, я бы хотел, чтобы они по ширине контейнера занимались 100% и одинаково по ширине распределялись.
Вот здесь также могу это заранее указать.
Смотрим, как у нас меняется состояние, как у нас меняется сводка, вводим имя сервера, нажимаем создать.
Пополнение баланса, что происходит, когда мы нажимаем копировать, какое уведомление всплывает.
Что происходит, когда, например, нажимаем копировать, тут, например, можно посмотреть, что происходит, когда мы что-то копируем.
Такое уведомление будет всплывать, так будет меняться иконка, такой тул тип будет возникать и так далее.
Ну и как выглядят пустые и ошибочные состояния.
Все это дело можно еще дорабатывать, пробовать и доводить до идеала, логику, прежде чем передавать в разработку.
Но теперь самое интересное, как нам это все отдать разработчику, потому что сейчас у нас все запущено на локалке и только здесь мы можем со всем этим работать.
Итак, база есть, каталог собран, теперь отдаем это разработке.
Передавать мы будем через GitHub.
Мы упоминали его, когда разбирали.
Мы упоминали его, когда говорили о том, как разработка устроена в общих чертах.
GitHub - это место, где живет и передается код.
Сейчас чуть конкретнее, как он устроен.
Ровно настолько, насколько нам нужно, как дизайнерам.
Проект на GitHub лежит в репозитории.
Считай, это папка проекта в облаке со всей историей изменений.
Просто называется это репозиторий.
Слово это можно запомнить.
Внутри репозитория есть разные ветки, отдельные копии проекта.
Них можно менять что угодно, не трогая основную версию.
Поэтому разработчики так и работают.
Вот есть у нас репозиторий, папка проекта и внутри несколько разных его копий, в которые каждый из разработчиков что-то делает.
Например, как мы делаем в школе Pixel Perfect.
Изначально я собрал костяк нашего сайта, собрал его компонентную базу, дизайн-систему и так далее.
Потом подключился Коля, тоже стал наполнять новыми страницами, механиками и так далее.
Я свой проект залил на гитхаб, дал к нему доступ у Коли и Коля в свою очередь агенту дал доступ к этому гитхабу.
Ну и я точно также дал Клоду доступ к своему гитхабу, чтобы туда все обновления заливать.
В итоге, есть у нас общий репозиторий, у Коли своя отдельная ветка, своя как бы копия этого проекта и моя отдельная, когда я вношу какие-то изменения, тестирую, работает или нет.
И третья ветка это main, основная, главная ветка, в которую в конечном итоге мы все эти изменения вносим, когда проверили, что все работает.
То есть изменения, которые внес Коля, плюс изменения, которые внес я, объединяем и закидываем в эту основную ветку.
Это называется у разработчиков "пушнуть в main".
Соответственно, как это может, например, выглядеть у тебя?
Вот есть у тебя твой проект, ты его на гитхаб залил.
Разработчик смотрит, возможно, куда-то катит сразу это в прот, размещает на серваке и так далее.
Ты работаешь над какой-то новой фичой.
Ты не можешь просто вот то, что сейчас видит разработчик, тот проект, который ты ему давал, что-то там резко заменить, поменять какие-то файлы и так далее.
Ну, это будет странно, он не будет понимать, что происходит и так далее.
Ну, и плюс тебе там нужно тестировать это все, подходить к этому итеративно.
Поэтому ты в отдельной ветке просто вносишь какие-то новые изменения, итерации, когда приходишь к какому-то результату, такой, да, окей, работает.
Можешь это пушнуть в основную ветку.
Ну, просто, говорят, пушнуть, как бы то же самое, что залить, там, заменить, обновить содержимое и так далее.
И также разработчик уже, например, имеет какой-то готовый проект, к которому ты просишь, чтобы тебе дали возможность подключиться.
Ты такой, все, я больше не просто дизайнер, я теперь вообще собираю весь продукт, дайте мне доступ.
Они просто делают для тебя отдельную ветку, не дают тебе доступ к основной, для того, чтобы ты там все не перелопатил, не изменил, не испортил.
Вот у тебя есть отдельная ветка с копией этого продукта, ты в ней можешь что угодно делать.
Наращивать какой-то новый функционал, собирать новые экраны, показывать ребятам, вот смотрите, круто, да, они такие, да, классно, вроде все безопасно, вроде все хорошо сделал.
Что тебе нужно сделать, как ни странно, зайти на GitHub, зарегистрироваться на нем и пока на этом все.
Вот, кстати, могу показать, как выглядит наш проект с сайтом.
Есть здесь у нас уже шесть разных веток.
Выглядит наш проект, вот сам по себе GitHub, сам проект, папка с этим проектом, то есть вот это называется репозиторий.
У нас там папочка Cloud, которая учитывает изменения, различные файлы, сам проект, его страницы, компонентная база, условия и так далее.
Также хорошим тоном считается, если у тебя есть readme к твоему проекту.
Здесь на GitHub предусмотрено, что он автоматически рядышком выводится и здесь описано, как это работает, что там должно быть и так далее.
Здесь мы находимся в ветке основной, она называется main.
Здесь самая финальная, самая вот главная, конечная версия продукта.
Есть также отдельные ветки Николай, Даниил, в которых мы работаем, вносим какие-то итерации дополнительные.
И еще под ветки, под отдельные там задачи, которые мы выполняли, под продукты тоже, чтобы не делать это в своих ветках.
Итак, предположим, на GitHub ты зарегистрировался, теперь что нужно сделать?
Нужно подрубить его к клоду.
Что мы для этого делаем?
Просто переходим на клод и здесь открываем коннекторы.
Как это сделать?
Customize.
Connectors.
И здесь подрубаем GitHub.
Я, честно говоря, не помню.
Он автоматически вот здесь сразу отдельно появляется или его нужно поискать так или иначе.
Вот строка поиска.
Пишем GitHub и подрубаем GitHub integration.
Нажимаем connect.
Нас перекидывает на GitHub.
У меня, видимо, в памяти остались какие-то все-таки параметры подключения, поэтому сейчас там пройти авторизацию не получится.
Но процесс там не особо отличается от любой другой авторизации.
После чего, когда здесь у нас все подключено, можем возвращаться в наш проект.
Здесь этот чатик нам нужно будет обновить.
Давай его заново открою.
Либо там VS Code можешь перезагрузить.
Короче, при создании новых подключений, мы уже неоднократно об этом говорили, нам нужно чатик перезагружать.
Теперь берем директиву handoff.
Она специально нужна, чтобы создать новый репозиторий и туда закидывать изменения.
Если у тебя репозиторий уже создан, он это понимает и вносит изменения в отдельную ветку.
Ну, если что, тебя спросят.
Мы уже, в принципе, с терминологией базовой разобрались.
Я думаю, ты поймешь, о чем идет речь.
Ну, как обычно, просим его запустить выполнение директивы.
Итак, после первичной настройки, после запуска директивы, он потребует от нас выполнить два шага.
Во-первых, создать сам репозиторий.
Уже знаем, что это такое.
И создать токен для него с полным доступом.
Он здесь подробно выводит все шаги для этого.
Давай сначала создадим репозиторий.
Заходим просто на свой аккаунт, на главную страницу.
Переходим в репозиторий.
Нажимаем New и назовем его Lesson 4, например.
Все.
Сразу можно visibility, видимость сделать private.
Чтобы никто там к вашему проекту не мог подключиться.
И нажимаем создать репозиторий.
Теперь эту страницу можно оставить.
Пускай она будет эта вкладка.
Давай разберемся с токеном.
Для этого нажимаем на свою иконку.
Переходим в настройки.
В настройках идем в самый конец.
Developer settings.
Здесь Personal access tokens.
И выбираем tokens classic.
Generate new token.
New token classic.
И как-нибудь его называем.
Например, дадим ему название Forkload Lesson.
Дата истечения у нас без этой даты.
Чтобы он работал сколько угодно.
И здесь можно просто проставить все.
Чтобы он ко всему давал доступ нашему агенту.
Нажимаем создать токен.
И копируем этот токен.
Обязательно.
Имея в виду, что повторно этот токен не появится.
У тебя только одна возможность его скопировать.
Поэтому копируем и закидываем агенту.
Итак, возвращаемся в Visual Studio Code.
Пишем ему токен.
Вставляем.
И название репозитория.
Можно вот прям так скопировать.
Отправляем сообщение.
И немного ждем.
После настройки он спросит залить вообще весь проект.
Или только его часть прототип.
Я попрошу залить именно React Base.
Ну и перед этим нужно перезапустить VS Code.
Чтобы все подключение установилось.
Запишу ему.
Перезапустил.
Только React Base.
И отправляем.
Итак, Клод сказал, что все сделал.
Все запушил.
Давай обновим страницу.
И убедимся в этом.
У нас появилась куча файлов.
Появилась основная ветка main.
Больше других веток нет.
Также он создал здесь readme.
В котором описал, что вообще здесь за проект.
Из чего он состоит.
Что тут у нас в принципе есть.
На этом все.
Это уже можно передавать ссылкой своему разработчику.
Например, здесь через https.
Скопировать.
Отправить ему.
На этом все.
Да, информация новая.
Достаточно сложная.
Потому что это уже мир разработки.
Но я думаю, что в целом не так много здесь информации.
Можно разобраться.
И все достаточно просто.
Мы разобрались, как создать полноценный storybook.
С которым будет удобно работать разработчику.
Который сможет одним нажатием кнопки сразу переносить компоненты в проект.
Разобрались, как запушить его на гитхаб.
Как поделиться этим проектом.
Как там зарегистрироваться.
Создать токен.
Дать Клоду доступ к нему.
И так далее.
По материалу урок получился объемный.
И теперь давай поговорим о домашнем задании.
Что нужно сделать.
Точно так же создать storybook.
Пройтись по нему.
Убедиться, что создались там все песочницы.
Компоненты.
Описания.
И что все в принципе перенеслось правильно.
При желании можешь попросить его доработать анимации.
Доработать логику поведения.
Создать какие-то новые варианты песочниц.
Или расширить компонентную базу.
Сразу в storybook без создания ее в фигме.
После чего точно так же создаем гитхаб.
Даем ему токен.
Подключаем Клод.
И пушим туда проект.
Для выполнения домашнего задания.
Будет достаточно просто сделать скрин.
Твоего репозитория.
Например, просто вот так.
И отправить в Zen Class.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания.
И увидимся в следующем уроке.